[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi le burn out c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui était dans la tête et
qui n'existait pas
[Musique]
je bricolais cette Twitter par jour en
moyenne
en plus de mon travail donc ça fait des
ça fait des journées pleines après ça me
détend quand même de bricoler c'est ce
que je me suis toujours dit mais en
réalité
au début ça détend puis après je
m'inflige un rythme sur le bricolage de
me dire il faut vraiment que ça soit
fini aujourd'hui et ça demain et je me
fais un programme et après un planning
et ce qui fait que ça devient comme
comme au travail pendant 20 ans David
rénove deux maisons tout en étant cadre
dans une usine de la région avant son
burn-out il y a plus d'un an il gère 45
personnes et sa maison est un chantier
permanent
pendant huit mois il remplace un
collègue malade gère deux équipes il
fait du 5h21 et à l'époque ça lui va le
taux d'implication de chacun est
différent et je peux le concevoir mais
moi j'ai l'impression que tout le monde
dans mon travail ou dans les autres
travail sont ralentis que ça va jamais
assez vite pour moi et j'ai toujours été
perçu comme ça et l'entreprise le sait
et puis s'en servait aussi puisque d'un
autre côté même si j'avais du stress et
c'est du bon stress et
David il est comme ça je me rendais bien
compte qu'autour de moi tout le monde
nous était fou enfin mes enfants qui
sont adultes maintenant me disaient mais
jamais je travaillerai comme tu
travailles et à quel prix et pourquoi
et puis entre le travail à l'usine et
les rénovations de maison un jour les
nerfs de David finissent par lâcher
je commençais à plus dormir le peu que
je dormais les 4-5 heures que je dormais
je les dormais assuré et du coup je
commençais à avoir une tension qui qui
montait j'ai été infirmerie au travail
et j'étais à 21 12 ou 21 16 et je
commençais à avoir du mal à imprimer les
choses à me concentrer
donc là c'est la médecine du travail qui
est interne à la société où je travaille
qui m'a dit tu rentres chez toi tu vas
voir ton médecin traitant je veux que tu
te reposes au moins ou deux mois et on
refera un point
[Musique]
Nathalie a travaillé dans le secteur
médico-social pendant 15 ans elle a été
responsable d'une association et puis un
jour trop de stress trop de missions à
accomplir et c'était le burn out
je travaillais avec deux équipes sur
deux départements différents et une
équipe celle avec qui le courant passait
très bien c'est une équipe que j'ai
recruté d'ailleurs en partie les
personnes de cette équipe me disaient
que j'en faisais trop que il y avait pas
besoin que le directeur soit si exigeant
que ça dans le profil du directeur avec
qui je travaillais c'était des
injonctions paradoxales en permanence
il y avait du harcèlement moral et puis
des exigences de plus en plus
importantes et de plus en plus
nombreuses chaque jour
un jour d'octobre 2016 c'est la mission
de trop et sa vie bascule impossible
pour Nathalie de répondre à une ultime
demande de sa hiérarchie
en l'espace de quelques heures
grandissant je suis partie de mon
travail et là arrivé à la maison
tout s'est effondré le lendemain matin
je pouvais plus me lever j'étais coincé
sur mon canapé impossible de me lever
pour aller travailler et puis des
douleurs qui me prenaient tout le corps
des douleurs physiques je pouvais plus
bouger j'avais l'impression d'avoir une
armure dans le dos
et puis je pleurais je pleurais je
pleurais j'arrivais plus à m'arrêter et
surtout j'avais l'impression de me
perdre de perdre mon identité j'ai
commencé à avoir des crises d'angoisse
aussi dans les dans les instants qui ont
suivi et je me suis rendu à l'urgence de
aux urgences de l'hôpital parce que je
sentais que je maîtrisais plus rien en
fait
il février 2022 il a fait un malaise
suite à une phrase que son responsable
aurait dit tu feras ce que je te dis de
faire parce que au service de prévention
et de santé au travail médecin et
psychologue abordent les cas de salariés
en souffrance et c'est au tour d'une
table qu'ils essayent de trouver des
solutions car suivre un salarié en
burn-out nécessite un accompagnement
individualisé
on a une limite en termes de charge
mentale et c'est cette limite là qu'ils
ont dépassé alors souvent on connaît la
limite de la charge physique mais dans
la charge mentale on l'a pas et c'est
cette surcharge quelque part qui les a
amenés au burn out sur investissement ça
peut être la surcharge de travail en
tout cas dans la notion de burn-out il y
a tout source cette notion de surcharge
les salariés décrivent très fréquemment
dans ce genre de situation une perte
une perte de sens de leur travail aussi
des situations les salariés ont vraiment
l'impression de perdre pied au travail
un des salariés qui sont des gens
professionnels donc ils vont essayer
malgré tout d'arriver à faire les tâches
qui leur incombent et vu qu'ils n'ont
plus ses capacités là ils vont augmenter
leur temps de travail parfois sont des
personnes qui se réveillent la nuit pour
traiter leur mère qui travaille le
week-end qui travaille pendant les
congés scolaires
[Musique]
quand le salarié craque c'est à la
médecine de prendre le relais pour David
le point de rupture est arrivé un jour
de mai il y a un an et demi il a été
arrêté trois mois
[Musique]
on m'a demandé de suivre un suivi
psychologique
j'y étais pour faire plaisir au médecin
et parce que j'avais pas le choix mais
pas pour moi en fait je me suis dit je
vais aller faire deux trois séances qui
sont vite fait et puis je vais retrouver
mon boulot et je vais redevenir comme
avant dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois
et puis ça c'est pas passé comme ça
on m'a quand même donné un peu de
médicaments des antidépresseurs des
choses comme ça
j'ai commencé à dormir plus c'est à dire
des nuits de 6h après 8h encore un peu
hachuré mais quand même des nuits et là
c'était horrible pour moi puisque
j'avais pu assez de temps avec tout ce
que j'avais entrepris tout ce que
j'avais commencé et pourquoi dormir avec
un si beau soleil
donc c'était très très compliqué je me
suis aperçu que le problème c'était plus
moi c'était pas forcément la société la
société en terme général c'est plus moi
qui m'inflige une cadence comme ça c'est
plus moi qui m'afflige à dire oui tout
le temps à tous les gens qui me
sollicitent à dire oui
à tout et puis quand tu commences à dire
non ben il se passe rien en fait les
gens aiment quand même et puis ça se
passe bien quand même
[Musique]
le point commun que l'on peut retrouver
c'est cette absence de pose de limite de
soi c'est à dire ne pas arriver à dire
non aux différentes missions ou
d'accepter des fois des missions qui
sont en dehors de nos compétences par
exemple il y a ce point commun souvent
c'est cette difficulté à poser le nom
après ce sont souvent des gens
consciencieux et les employeurs vont
plutôt vers donner des missions à ces
gens consciencieux et ils ont raison
quelque part c'est normal dans leur
production dans leur productivité
d'entreprises mais la personne en face
est bien elle elle a du mal à dire stop
je ne peux plus
après 6 années de suivi psychiatrique et
d'accompagnement médical la vie de
Nathalie est toujours marquée par le
burn out
dans les symptômes qui persistent encore
aujourd'hui
je fais des grosses des crises
d'angoisse quand il y a des situations
de stress très importantes
j'ai peur de la foule je fais des
cauchemars encore même si ça s'estompe
ils sont encore présents
et puis la chose la plus importante
c'est que j'ai un sommeil qui a été
complètement massacré c'est vraiment ça
qui a été détruit la confiance en moi
j'ai tout perdu vraiment tout tout perdu
jusqu'à ne plus savoir qui j'étais perte
d'identité totale donc il a fallu
reconstruire ça petit à petit je pense
que je ne récupérerai jamais la totale
confiance en moi
dans ces situations la mission de la
médecine du travail c'est d'accompagner
les salariés à la reprise et ça se
traduit souvent par une adaptation de
poste le temps pour le salarié de
reprendre ses marques dans l'entreprise
après les trois mois d'absence sur
consécutifs c'était difficile dans ma
tête je j'arrivais un petit peu tête
basse me
sentant moi un petit peu
rabaissé alors que tout le monde était
bienveillant avec moi la société dans
laquelle je travaille m'a donné des
postes aménagés m'a donné un poste qui
était plus responsabilité
mon salaire a été maintenu les horaires
je faisais vraiment ce que je voulais
j'ai été en arrêt maladie 3 ans
et à la suite à la fin de ces trois
années j'ai été convoquée par la CPAM
j'ai rencontré un médecin conseil qui
m'a expliqué que
dans mon cas avec tous les symptômes que
j'avais je ne pourrai plus jamais
retravailler
et qu'elle me mettait en invalidité
parfois il est impossible de reprendre
une activité professionnelle Nathalie en
est l'exemple aujourd'hui elle a changé
ses priorités elle se reconstruit
avec mon époux depuis quatre ans
maintenant nous avons des ruches
nous avons pris des cours dans un rue
chez école parce que c'était une passion
que lui avait et qu'il voulait partager
avec moi donc quand il y avait ces cours
lui c'était la tête et moi les gens
parce que je n'arrivais rien à retenir
mais
aujourd'hui
j'accepte plus mes actions sur sur des
choses qui me font du bien et ce sera
pas le travail je le sais
le burn out je le vois un petit peu
comme une opportunité parce que là j'ai
50 ans je me dis si j'avais continué à
travailler comme je travaille aussi bien
personnellement que professionnellement
je sais pas jusqu'où j'aurai été mon
père est décédé à 62 ans mon grand-père
58 et je me dis pourquoi en fait
et là je vis plus pour moi
si dans les années 70
type allemand le secteur médico-social
aujourd'hui le burnout concerne tous les
milieux tous les métiers
surcharge peut-être la prévention du
burn-out elle est quand même difficile
alors déjà auprès de du futur bird out
si on l'avait appelé comme ça elle
difficile dans le sens où
souvent ils ne voient pas il ne prennent
pas conscience eux-mêmes qu'ils ont une
difficulté et qui sont qui sont déjà
dans la phase d'alerte du syndrome
d'épuisement professionnel donc ça c'est
difficile sur la prévention de
l'individu dans l'entreprise plus on
fera de sensibilisation au stress au
travail plus on présentera ce qu'on
appelle les risques psychosociaux
qu'est-ce qui fait source de stress
qu'est-ce qui est source de stress dans
l'entreprise et qui pourront les
détecter là on sera sur de la prévention
le syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
nécessite un suivi psychologique et
médical précis adapté à chaque situation
aujourd'hui David et Nathalie se
reconstruisent à leur rythme avec leurs
proches
les traitements que je prends je pense
qu'à un moment donné ça a été une
béquille c'est vrai que il faut que je
continue je peux pas les arrêter comme
ça il y a un suivi psychiatrique et
psychologique j'espère qu'un jour je les
diminuerai que je les arrêterais
j'espère la valeur travail a changé
effectivement je suis quand même
impliqué je vais faire ce qu'on me dit
mais je vais pas aller au-delà pareil
pour pour chez moi j'ai des travaux à
finir
avant je me serais jamais j'aurais
jamais fait une sieste parce que j'ai du
travail maintenant je me dis c'est pas
grave c'est pas fou aujourd'hui ben je
le ferai demain et puis si c'est pas
fait quelle importance
le burn out touche plus de 2 millions de
salariés chaque année un chiffre en
constante augmentation la souffrance au
travail est un chantier important pour
nous entreprises depuis janvier une
formation secourisme en santé mentale et
d'ailleurs obligatoire pour les agents
du service public un outil
supplémentaire pour pallier les
situations de détresse psychologique au
travail
[Musique]